researchers are actually warning that
the pandemic may affect the mental
health of children and teenagers
more than adults during and after this
period of isolation
psychologists and cbs news contributor
lisa demour says
we should all work to prevent mental
health crisis in young people she joins
us now
welcome lisa you know you've heard the
term new normal
i think the question is what can we do
to help our children
during this time
well we have sort of bad news and better
news i think it's become quite clear
that the school year is going to be very
disruptive for kids and this is a
very hard thing to stomach for them
because they are already
five months into a pandemic that has
really worn all of us down
no kid had the summer they had in mind
even simple things like hanging out with
friends or going to the pool
didn't happen for most kids and i think
there is tremendous anxiety about what
school will look like
whether kids are physically going to
school or not
i think kids are anxious about what will
unfold
so the better news is that we have
decades of psychological research that
tell us
that there are two things that make an
enormous difference in terms of helping
children along
and their warmth and structure so in all
of the challenges we are facing
those are what parents should focus on
really making sure that
home is a compassionate and friendly
place
and that life is predictable that there
are routines the kids can count on
whatever comes their way how important
are those routines because i feel like
as a parent it's easy to fall into the
routine of
eating breakfast as late as nine or ten
o'clock when normally
they would be eating at six or seven in
the morning
and making sure that they're getting
outside how important is that routine
you know when there's so much disruption
right now even those really basic things
can go out the window
so it is important to have routines in
part because it gives kids a sense of
control when everything else feels
pretty out of control
and routines let us make sure that
things happen like
getting adequate sleep and just to recap
little kids
elementary school kids need 11 hours of
sleep a night middle schoolers need 10
high schoolers need 9 hours of sleep a
night
they need physical activity they need a
safe
and predictable place where they are
studying and doing school work
and a time they know they do it they
need to be helping around the house
helping in the community if they can do
so and then also they need time for
leisure
time with friends they need to have fun
things in their lives right now more
than ever really
what's the concern do you think about
the lasting impact this will have on
children and
particularly with those in that
adolescent stage
you know we do worry this is going on so
long
and we know that chronic stress is not
good for anybody and for kids this is a
long time in what
are relatively short lives for them and
we worry about
rising rates of depression and we worry
about anxiety and we also worry about
the fact that a lot of kids have been
exposed to trauma
so we're keeping an eye on that that
said
parents can provide guardians can
provide a powerful buffering force for
kids
and if we are safe and steady presences
for our children
and if we help them to know how each day
is going to unfold even if we're having
new routines week by week
as the strangeness of this year unfolds
it helps kids to know what's coming even
if it's not exactly what any of us want
and lisa a lot of parents as you know
are struggling as well at what point
do you seek help professional help and
if you can't do that
what's your advice
so we expect a fair degree of distress
right now
in parents and kids um this is a very
hard time it would actually be strange
if people were not distressed
it's time to worry though when the way
that people actually of any age
are coping with distress isn't healthy
so we worry
if people are cutting others off or if
they're cranky all the time
we worry about substance misuse we would
be concerned if a person is struggling
to take care of themselves not sleeping
while not eating well
or if they become so anxious or
depressed that they are having a hard
time getting through the day
that's when we would want people to
reach out and
right now it continues to be the case
that
most clinicians are taking care of
patients digitally working with them
through digital means and what i would
say is i hope everyone
could have access everyone should have
access to professional mental health
care
and in the absence of that you know the
more warmth structure
love support and predictability we can
provide kids
the better all right lisa demour with
some great advice there thank you so
much